my parents would come and the directors
whoever was running it would always be
like you know your son's very talented
he's got the thing and my parents oh
thank you and we get in the car my dad's
like that [ __ ] is crazy
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
With Me George Lopez let's do the show
because I got a lot of things to do
things
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Lopez George Lopez oh my God OMG
hey
[Music]
um
you guys are married have children how
was the pandemic
how's the pandemic for you guys gosh it
was
um
it was first of all on the one hand as a
touring comedian it was nice because my
kids at that point were probably 12 and
10 or like 11 and 9 and so it was nice
to be home
and we got to go and watch a lot of
movies
that like I wouldn't have had a chance
to watch and then I got to watch with my
kids and that's you know I was just
listening to Anderson Cooper's podcast
he was talking about how when his mother
passed away he said the last two weeks
of her life were really some of the best
time he spent with her he said we just
sat there and watched old movies that
she loved wow and I was like you know
what that's what movies does it brings
us movies or music brings us together
yeah you know so for us we'd be sitting
there with our kids and I'd be like oh
my God Trading Places Eddie Murphy you
got to see this I know yeah you know or
or uh Flash Dance my wife loved
Flashdance just those movies
and then and then and then because the
town was closed down I got to get on a
bike with my kids I'd bike them all over
town I'd be like let's go over here so
there was there was some beauty to it
you know
um obviously financially you're like oh
my gosh I'm not making any money right
um but then again thank God you know I
tell people we're lucky we're blessed
because I know that like when when it
first started I was hearing about people
who were living in their cars and stuff
I know you know what I'm saying I'm
saying I'm lucky that I was able to you
know have money saved up to be able to
get through it I mean you don't realize
how much goes out until you don't have
any coming in yes and then you're like
wait a minute is this is this like this
every month it's just like every month
yeah you don't think about it because
of
um you know you got the you got the the
water in the ocean yeah got goes up and
down and you're going along and then all
of a sudden
they pull the water out there you know
yeah and how long nobody knew how long I
didn't I didn't think that like I was in
uh I was saying oh you drink Moss okay
what is it oh cream you're good yeah oh
guys cheers gentlemen sure man hey it's
nice I didn't know this would be like
this is beautiful beautiful cheers you
know uh yeah cheers and uh
you know it's it's it's February and
they're guys they say uh middle of April
I ain't gonna make it the middle of
April
now now June the middle of June nah I'm
not going to make it yeah I won't make
it that far two was it two years two
years yeah
it was it was crazy because I'm sorry
but real quickly like the other part of
me as a performer
because you know it's in you yeah so you
got to do something so I'm sitting
around like what am I doing I'm loving
being with the family we're opening up
wine because you know everybody started
like we were having wine yeah although
it's great we're gonna drink some wine
and hang out with the family but like by
a weekend you're like I gotta I gotta do
something so then I get on my Instagram
I start doing Instagram lives oh and I
have a great time I do like 15 minutes
Instagram I go this is great and then I
go I'll see you guys tomorrow
and I come back tomorrow and I go see
you guys tomorrow in about a weekend I'm
going holy moly now every day at around
five o'clock I gotta go do Instagram
live and I'm not writing material that
fast I'm just talking about everything
that's going on in my life yeah and um
and we had like it literally like as
soon as a pandemic hit our dryer stopped
working
so I had to go out into the laundromat
right and then we had this little mouse
a rat that was running around the house
and so every day I come up I give an
update I'd be like I haven't found the
mouse yet I got the guy coming so it was
fun for a while right right but after a
while I was like this is like I I can't
keep this pace up it was pretty it's
it's vast it's almost like somebody
leaving you in the desert and say okay
you got to find your just keep walking
and I guess you'll see yeah but you
don't know how far you're gonna walk
that's part that's a good that's a great
analogy because that's part of it
because you don't if you knew oh I just
got to get to blah blah blah September
end of September I'm good yeah but when
you don't
you go and then I said I started now
again a lot of comedians did not want to
do Zoom shows I'll be honest with you I
fell in love with zoom shows and I'll
tell you why because as communities we
got material right but and when you do
crowd work you know the guys in the
front hey what's up bubble you're
talking to him no one behind him really
sees him the people around him right
when you're on zoom and you got 100
people on your zoom and I would sit
there I start doing material and then I
would just start clicking through to
find the guy ah and I'd be like hey Tom
is that a parrot I'd be like look up Tom
and now everyone's seeing Tom and that
became like it was it was so I was
having fun with it man Russell Peters
know that because I think
was he was he was he he's all crowd work
oh yeah yeah oh oh my God he would have
been like for Russell that would have
been I mean it's it's finally finding
the key to the Holy Grail oh my God
because it was so listen you don't know
how many times
I had like
I get booked on something
actually the truth is I was hesitant to
do any Zoom shows because we you know
comedians a little snobby and we're like
we need an audience I remember early on
George I saw it was either John Legend
or Chris Martin one of these guys was
sitting his piano and he's like hey
World let me play a little song and he's
playing his songs and he plays another
song and I'm watching I go I'm so
jealous I go he doesn't need to have a
he doesn't need laughs
we need laughs
and I go he could do the same song 10
days in a row his fans will come back
come back yeah we got to come up with
new material every day and when he
laughs yes so the key was the first time
I did it was somebody was like oh we'll
do a fundraiser because early on I was
you know we were all doing like oh
fundraiser for this not the other so
I'll do it it ended up being so much fun
because it was actually it was actually
sponsored by these guys at Google and
then they said I said you guys want to
do a zoom they go no no we'll send you
the Google link and the thing wasn't
working like the sound wasn't working
yeah so as soon as I was able so one of
the one of the employees
like called me on my phone and put my
phone to the speaker I go first of all
let me just say something I'm going to
sell all my Google stock you guys suck I
mean come on and then I went off it was
10 minutes of just making fun of them
yep and I was like this is amazing and
how would you get paid
I got different like like so there was
times when you do a gig like a comedian
was putting together this is and George
you know how it is man like I felt like
man I was like again knock on wood I do
fine in my life yeah and I'd saved up
enough I was fine and then you hear
about friends that are like you know
they need they need to make a living so
then a comedian will hit you up and be
like hey I got this show there's 10 of
us I go great man no problem I didn't
want to get paid and then he goes and
send me your vemo I go wow and he's like
well they're gonna tip us I go really oh
that became so that became part of the
fun where I was like I was like guys I
just did the Kennedy Center now I'm
working for tips yeah and it became so I
could take it away anything like 10
minutes later no I'm taking that five
so there was gigs like that and then
there was gigs where like some dude was
like oh is my I'm having a party and he
was you know he's like I got money and
you know whatever was like 7 500 10
grand whatever it was for his him and
his family I was all right no problem
that's awesome man yeah yeah you know so
it ran the gamut you know there was
there was gigs that were like
universities were like yeah you have
money at 25 Grand to do a zoom show like
this and I click off and I go back into
my house I go I mean I go man if I get
this 10 of these a year I'd be happy I'd
be excited I think it's another way of
of still keeping it to keeping it
keeping it going I mean I don't think
you need to there's people that don't go
out
I do a lot of lecturing and I don't like
to do zoom zoom lectures because I like
to be able to personally talk to people
you know the crowd or ask a question I
like the closeness of it I I can't
if I get offered a zoom to do and zooms
with who like the Goa and investigator
groups police groups anybody but I just
not the Goa I don't even know what the
Goa is gordos of America
[Laughter]
you don't have to fit in the screen
it's like not having a screen I can only
hear it better
not even from Goa well that's for you
because you got to do because you got to
do legit like for us as comedians they
want us to be funny right so I think
that's part of it do they want us to be
funny yes well obviously when they book
you right so how about that we have to
we have a job where like a cook could
cook for years and maybe have one
complaint oh yeah and the mobile is a
Master Chef and we do shows and they go
yeah I don't know man yeah oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I think it's not as good as
the last time I saw him George I saw him
oh no no yeah he used to be way better
than he uh he was tonight dude I've had
so many times where I've been been on
stage this usually happens like at a
corporate event because let's face it
when you're doing your show people
bought the tickets 90 some odd percent
of those people are excited to see you
and they're going to give you love
beginning to end and even if they go oh
he wasn't as good as they still love you
yep right but when you do these
corporate events I did I did I did I did
one where I was like it wasn't it was a
bar mitzvah and this is one this is one
of those things I mean first of all I
mean hats off for for do for even trying
it yes and then what what well it was
one of these things I was like I don't
want the apartment it's been the guy got
into this he's like listen man my kid's
a fan my family's a fanboy it's gonna be
the Waldorf Astoria that I go I'll fly
out for that I go out there and you know
how this is so the guy goes we've flown
in a band from Israel 40 person band
they can play after you oh great
big one of the biggest enemies for a
comedian is a dance floor because now
these people may as well be on the other
end zone they're in another world so I
tell the guy go listen man I go I I go
when I'm up just bring the seats onto
the Dance Floor he goes don't worry the
kids will come they'll sit to fill up
the front I go all right I didn't
realize when he said kids he meant like
four-year-olds oh
I started my act and all of a sudden now
I'm babysitting oh my they're pointing
up who is this and I'm like don't you
guys have parents now I'm getting
heckled by four-year-olds I'm looking in
the audiences like 90 year old
grandmother's eating chicken staring at
me and they'd hired me because as you
know when they hire you they're big fans
of yours right but exactly what you just
said I go I know they're sitting there
right now going this guy is much funnier
on YouTube and so I started leaning into
that where I was like listen I know you
guys are judging me and going like you
know I'm gonna watch this videos he's
not good as good on live so I get
through it and it was one of those
things where they wanted me to do like
20 or 30 minutes but what'd you do well
I ended up doing like 45 man I was
looking for I was looking for a big
laugh to get out on I started going to
Old Time jokes I was like they know the
old times so I started doing the old
time jokes not hitting finally at the
very end you know I'm like thank you
good night I get upstairs I go right to
the bar get myself a little tequila and
this just so happened a friend of mine
happened to be there he came over I'm
like hey man he's like yeah man and
here's what's funny about that because I
thought oh man now they're all looking
down at me but five minutes later that
band was on stage playing music they
came and grabbed me and they pulled me
in to dance with them and I go that's
all they I should have just I should
have just been hired to Come dance with
these yeah yeah yeah because they just
want to be around you
but they'll judge your material
yeah I went to a fundraiser and Rudy was
performing
what's the [ __ ] irony there his whole
[ __ ] life is a fundraiser he he was
performing and there were kids on the
Dance Floor running around you and he
was dying he was dying
and you know how once I get laughing I
was laughing so loud not because he was
so funny but because he was dying yeah
yeah he'd like and I just started
laughing and we're friends and I just
started laughing because he's dying
there couldn't do [ __ ] and once he got
off stage he just said hey cabron you
were laughing because I was dying that's
why you were laughing and it was and he
still remembers it it's tough to see
here you know I I I was always a uh
horses for courses like I I stick to my
own I don't really I didn't really do
well at corporates I mean I did but I
didn't like to the hit and miss aspect
of it yeah yeah and uh you know
um they would say
yeah Tommy could do whatever he wants
one time I said
I did something for the Boy Scouts it
was Zero cussing oh God and somebody
yelled out something I said it won't be
too much longer now [ __ ]
25 12.50 a bad word a bad word mother
and [ __ ] go together like peanut
butter and jelly yeah yeah yeah of
course and the guy was I mean a whole
hour
and then that toward the end because the
guy you know and and it took away all of
the Goodwill that I did yeah give him
your bucket 25 oh yeah 37.50 yeah but
but it's like you know
I stopped doing the things where
they hire you and then they expect you
to be to not be you oh yeah yeah yeah
that's a good point yeah yeah you're
right you're right you're right it is
it's a tough I I always find I always
want to find because I'm like you said
like there's you know there's some
Comics who are great joke writers right
and they're great at getting up there
they're clean and they're just gonna do
boom boom boom boom boom Oh you need a
half an hour I got you half an hour
right that's it and I'm not even gonna
judge myself I'm just gonna get up there
do it and they're perfect for corporates
right I like you I don't I'm not that
not that I'm that there but I cuss you
know I cuss and also a lot of times I go
like for me I always gotta go like
is the owner of the company Persian or
Arab or like I'm trying to find my fan
base right I go did my fan base bring me
to this
and sometimes I say yes like I did uh
there was a corporate event for Jack in
the Box
um uh franchisees and it was an Indian
guy and a Persian guy my wife's Indian
I'm Persian they know me they brought me
and it was listen dude this was
fantastic because because you get a
bunch of for me like you we do great in
front of immigrants right because you
talk about your background so I started
doing my thing and then at some point I
started going I was like let me see
who's out here so you know you got some
white folks you got some black folks we
got like Filipino you got Mexican you
got everything because that's what we
hustle hustle and it was so much fun
because then you hit gold sometimes so I
go I go wait a minute who's who's got
franchises in other countries where
where are you from Philippines what do
you call it in Philippines what's Jack
in the Box the Philippines and you know
the ladies like you know Papa in the box
or whatever I'm like pop it in the Box
you know what I mean yeah right gold
right gold yeah so I have you have those
types where it's your people and it's
fantastic and then you have types where
you're like wait a minute how'd they get
me so I had one recently for it was like
um it was something like uh um uh home
uh tools and like some big company to
sell stuff to like uh um Home Depot and
I go and I again I go okay Builders all
right Persian Armenian I don't know
Mexican what is it yep because no they
go the audience is like a bunch of good
old boys from Texas I go what
and they go yeah and I go I'm in trouble
and I went up in front of that audience
and now the other thing you you realize
this was just like last year
we live in a time where even if you're
not trying to be political you're
political so I had a whole joke about
like the mask and how I wore the mask
and there was people who didn't want to
wear the mask and depending on like if
they like you look at them and be like
you know look at their face and be like
if the mask wasn't on you're like oh you
believe the election was fake or was it
real you know like oh yeah like real
fake real fake do you believe the Earth
is uh round or flat you know what I'm
saying it's like making fun of and I
realize that's political to these guys
you know what I'm saying and so I went
on stage I was like I can't do that I
can't do this and like you said it made
me kind of I was like okay I got to do
45 minutes and I gotta find all the
family making fun of my kids you know
what I'm saying and even then
I leaned into for a second because I
think they brought is it what's the name
is it uh the the Asian uh the Asian guy
that's uh he's he's got that he's I
think he's from Texas
um Henry Cho Henry Cho I think they had
Henry Cho before and they'd loved him so
I was like all right I'll talk about how
I'm Muslim but I'm not really Muslim
muslim-ish he's Korean with a with a
Southern accent exactly so I wanted to
talk about how Muslim but a muslim-ish
I'm not really religious you know what
I'm saying right and so I did some of
that and then at some point towards the
end of the show I was like oh man I was
like oh Jesus or something I said
something oh God or something and the
guy and there's some guy in the back is
like oh Lord Jesus he's like yelled like
he got all into it like he got offended
that I was saying like oh Jesus or
whatever so he was yelling at me and I
was like calm down I told you I'm not
religious and then everyone's got the
you know young tables laughing people
are looking at me like what and then I
was like Allahu Akbar I said that just
for fun
I could tell someone were like what the
hell oh my God I couldn't help myself at
that point yeah I mean
it's all it's all a bit about
it's a little bit of a fantasy anyways
yeah it really is yeah a little bit of
fantasy yeah
um Gil was a detective for how many
years you worked 17 years uh I was a
homicide cop for well how many six had a
38 wow
but were you a detective or not you were
always on homicide comp no no don't be
putting [ __ ] on your resume sorry I was
I've worked homicides for 26 out of 38
years
yeah Los Angeles L.A County Sheriff [ __ ]
yeah that's no joke cut the night stock
so really
really he was the he was the guy
everybody else said it was too more than
one person and he would he said
this is the work of one person wow and
that and I think that I think maybe the
Night Stalker might have kept
crime solidified like it created a crime
world like they have crime cons yeah and
uh and everybody was together the cold
Community you know cops were not hated
then you know they if you wanted to
solved yeah I didn't think anybody hates
cops I mean there's some bad you know or
bad and everything you hate cops I mean
I mean what's the option yeah you can't
hate cops you got like you said I think
I think it's kind of like again it goes
to the image the general image right
there's probably some people who are
like man you know [ __ ] cops right but
but as you just said because that's
that's what happened with the you know
defund the police slogan right because
the first thing was matter of fact I
remember first of all how about a slogan
nobody knows what it is yeah it's not
you defund
you know that's yeah yeah well that is
is I was talking to this FBI guy who was
like it's like it's reimagined the
police because you shouldn't send out a
cop when there's some homeless guy who's
kind of like having a breakdown you got
to send out someone who's and that you
know knows how to deal with that right
um but I remember being actually I went
to the black lives matter protest when
it first was in LA and uh right there on
um like at uh the Pan Pacific Park I
remember walking around and they were
like you know you know no justice no
peace you know uh you know we George
Floyd you know we stand with Joe Floyd
and then when they were like they were
like do you find the police I was like I
kind of like the police being around if
I need them you know what I'm saying so
it yeah I agree I I you know it's
there's a Nuance there
I think that yeah I mean we all you know
somebody's got to bring the old lady's
trash cans in there you go you know I I
can sit there and say that during that
time I could talk about being doing what
I was doing
now you know it's kind of like when I
came back from Vietnam you didn't talk
about Vietnam now I don't talk about
what I did because of the defund the
police
anti- police scent uh sentiment did you
ever use your badge for like if if I was
if I was a cop or a police officer or a
detective or a [ __ ] Explorer Scout I
don't give a [ __ ] and I had a badge I
would have girls sucking my dick with
that badge Bad Lieutenant Bad Lieutenant
12 years old
I would I think I would have been a Bad
Lieutenant no like they they wouldn't
even have to if they did my fingerprints
they would have panocha on it
uh thing
oh I know why that Ah that's funny yeah
just let us just let us wipe your hand
down no no that didn't happen you know I
think I would be that
I mean you can't do it anymore you know
the thing the thing is like there was
like there was a time there was a time
when when cops like the new the
neighborhood knew the guy or you know
what I'm saying there was that now the
number like there's Ellie's a big place
right and again look we all know it's
you you know you always say it's like
it's not about it's about how you do
things right you can either you can
either be an [ __ ] about it or you
could be nice about it it was even back
in the 70s I would be doing breathalyzer
when I was working Patrol in the 70s the
people knew me yeah the neighbor hey
here he comes you know they they knew
who I was because I reached out to the
people yeah they were afraid to cut you
know they were afraid no hey we're all
the same same people this is just a job
and so I did get along with everybody I
used to think a cop never got afraid
you know yeah yeah yeah that's what you
think yeah you think they show up
they're the they're bigger than ever
they're more they're bigger than
everybody else there they'll control the
situation you're right they're actors
they're just good actors yeah they are
yeah they have insecurities that's what
they have to be yeah and well that's
like you know the move that's from the
movies Dirty Harry and all this other
stuff you go this guy's just badass he's
gonna handle it right you're right you
know yeah I grew up in Marin and Tiburon
which was like you were talking about
murders like we had like one murder and
a hundred years wasn't Robin Williams
from out there Ron wisdom out there too
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um he actually went to the the I went to
the same high school he went to Redwood
High School yeah and um tibron was a
place where like uh uh the cops would
coach the baseball team so you knew the
guy Dave he's my coach I'm saying yeah
wow and and there was there was no crime
like there was there was very little
crime there
um but there was you know you had trust
the only thing was like okay oh they
pulled you over for speeding again you
know that was amazing right you know
um
but yeah it ended up in Tiburon though
because we moved so we left we left Iran
and your mother and father still alive
my father passed away in 09 my mother's
still alive uh so I was born in Iran in
72 left Iran in late 78 as protests were
happening in the streets of Iran right
so similarly you still remember the
sound and the colors of that dude I
remember I remember my father was a
successful businessman all right he had
an electric company that did well and
then and then at one point the Shahs
regime the Shah being the former King
and I say that because younger people
don't know about it so if they're
listening right now they might not know
um the Shahs regime nationalized
electricity but my father told me the
story he goes someone from the regime
called me down and goes hey we've chosen
your company as being one of the
companies we're gonna you know
subcontract with so that really helped
him like really go off right and my dad
the the closest fictional character that
I can relate to as my father was Don
Corleone from The Godfather because my
dad was somebody who people would come
to and be like hey my kid you know is my
kids got to do mandatory military
service any way you can get him out and
he'd be like let me make some calls he
was that guy his friends were like you
know chief of police generals this that
he was and he was also very uh generous
yeah or as we say in Persian you say
large large but with a J large I'm very
large the guy's large yeah you got to be
large you know what I'm saying and so um
and again that's a cultural thing right
you know so my dad would be the guy who
would like I don't know if you're going
on vac you take the whole like you take
everybody's families on a vacation to
wherever Phil we're all going let's go
oh wow that kind of guy so late 78
protests began and so growing up I just
all I remember as a kid I was like six
years old when I left all I remember as
a kid American culture has so much
influence around the world so I remember
my comic books Spider-Man Batman I
remember Muhammad Ali yeah Muhammad Ali
was loved every Muslim country love
Muhammad Ali yes right so I remember as
a kid I had all of his toys he was my
hero you know and when I came to America
and I learned about the things he stood
for he became even more of my hero right
sure
um and then and then what happens is
these protests begin right and
I remember being a kid and all of a
sudden
there was a curfew 10 o'clock lights out
so I remember me and my cousin would be
like looking out of the street and
there'd be cop cars going by flashing
lights into the windows and then we
would hear protests in the distance and
we would hear gunshots of stuff I
remember one time having to go down to
the basement because we heard like they
were like everyone in the basement and
my dad was already in America on
business so my mom got me and my sister
everybody we ran downstairs into our
basement just waiting we don't and as a
kid I don't know what's going on you
know what I'm saying
um and the way I always talk like to say
it my dad came to America
he was on business in New York and he
told my mom listen things aren't looking
good why don't you come out bring the
two older kids as me and my sister six
and eight and I had a baby brother who
was like just about a year old he goes
why do you come for about you know uh
come for two weeks let things cool down
you guys can go back and I would say we
came we packed for two weeks we stayed
for 40 something years wow you know what
I'm saying it just got it got more and
more and more what about the brother
so my brother was one at the time we
left them back uh in Iran and then like
a year later he came like through family
and stuff he came back he came to
America and the truth is he struggled
his whole life we lost him in 2014.
um addiction stuff so he I think he
struggled with that his whole life
because you know how as a young as a
young person
um those first years are very formative
oh yeah you know so I'm guessing us
being away there was separation and all
that you know and he was a great kid his
name's Kashi and he was like my you know
I had two young I have one other younger
brother right now
um but uh but yeah we lost Kashi uh in
2014. yeah yeah sorry did he have it did
he have it growing up and I just kind of
never could never get he was so he was
this kid who was charismatic man and he
was uh just like again one of these he
he you know my father I think being who
he was he he put some pressure on all of
us and and not a not an a bad way but he
was like you know I'm your like when
your dad is yeah you know there's this
this King Kong like your dad shows up
he's like throwing around money and
running everything you're like oh I want
to be like that guy right right and then
also he tells you your jobrani's son
don't ever forget that like you're my
you know I have a name don't mess my
name up right so it's the oldest son I
took that on my shoulders and as a
matter of fact like I probably could go
to therapist talk about like want to be
a people pleaser and just like always
want to take care of everybody right you
know what I'm saying
um and I think that my brothers got a
little bit of that pressure on them and
I think that my brother Kashi his
problem was he was a great baseball
player great guy everybody loved him
um I think that one of the issues he had
was
um because his who his father was and it
got in his mind like well I should
always I should I I don't need to like
work at like a lower level I should
always be at the top level so I remember
when he was in high school I got him a
job I was working as a waiter I was in
college at the time I was at UCLA so I
got a job at the Sports Club LA at that
point which was like the hottest hottest
Sports Club in town so I got a job so I
can have a membership like Magic Johnson
would come in and say yeah yeah and I
was like the waiter at the restaurant so
they had a cafe on the side and he was
in high school I go hey hey bro you know
I get you a job you you know get a
because because me being the oldest son
I I always had jobs and delis and this
and that and I and and I like that work
ethic he came to the deli and worked for
two weeks and after two weeks he's like
man I don't be taking orders from these
people here like these people like you
know he's like these people are losers
and I was like oh dude that's the wrong
mentality right like well you got to be
like you got to get because he thought
he should be CEO
you understand what I'm saying yeah
um so yeah man it was it was it was a a
tough loss it's a trip because sometimes
people have these these traits that I
mean you know my friend Ernie who passed
in April I knew that guy my whole life
and the way he was flaky and unreliable
and last minute oh hey man I can't make
it [ __ ] now like okay well you
got the card like we were gonna go do
stand-up yeah in the 70s yeah 80. yeah
and he'd call at 7 15.
hey man I'm gonna make it so I would
have a car and I and I in a way it made
me I went I went back to my room I
closed the door I'm like okay well you
can't rely on this dude so if you're
gonna go to be do stand up you're gonna
have to go without them and I didn't
really didn't want to go alone yeah and
and I would go by myself and be awkward
by myself and all that other [ __ ] by
myself and you wouldn't get on and drive
back or if you did poorly you're getting
a [ __ ] car and you're like man oh my
God I was awful you want somebody to be
with everybody what the [ __ ] man yeah
and uh he was just that way his whole
life yeah I mean and it just eventually
I just got kind of tired of
an unreliable guy you've known your
whole life yeah and you know when you
look at that you probably can go back
all of us can go back to our childhood
and it'll explain explain why we are how
we are right like your relationship with
your parents as a kid Etc and so
you take that and you add on top of that
obviously addiction like I see it now
it's like it's heartbreaking all this
stuff like these kids are with the
Fentanyl and this and that and you go
God like you really wish because for us
in our house as much as my father was
this lion he also was a big drinker and
culturally in the Persian Community it
was like okay to smoke uh they would
smoke this basically it's like a opium
kind of a thing it was kind of like weed
because because we're like right next to
Afghanistan right so they'd be smoking
that stuff and so but it wasn't wheat it
was like weed plus it's wheat plus it's
opium basic yeah so they sit around they
get you know they get high but for them
they were functioning that was part of
their culture right so my dad like my
dad passed a 76 he goes listen I've
lived 700 years he goes because he's
seen a lot he's done a lot he's been you
know and um and but but the problem you
don't think about is oh the effect that
has on kids like like for me I saw my
dad drinking it was no big deal so at
the age of 14 I was with my friends
we're like you know at my friend's house
drinking right
you go okay that's you know this seems
fine but then when you have your own
kids you go gosh I I really hope they
can have healthier Outlets rather than
going into and casual drinking is fine
or you know wheat or whatever it is but
it's uh it's it it's it's scary it's
scary when you see where it can lead
like when you've lost a brother to it
you go okay this can actually go really
South really fast yeah yeah and there is
uh
you know I had my my uncle Roger you
know he was like my favorite uncle and
uh he was just you know always worked in
a car wash and you know he goes I know
he goes he said my dream is to own a car
wash so one Christmas I gave my water
hose he got all [ __ ] Maddie
I thought it was a fun joke you know
he's like what's this well I remember he
opened it up and he just like I just
crushed him back oh wow that's a [ __ ]
joke to you yeah I said hey man yeah you
got to wash cars you get [ __ ] hoes
man yeah yeah yeah yeah and he was just
again I don't think he wanted to be to
own a car wash he said it yeah so at
least he could have something yeah you
know my dream is to own a car wash yeah
yeah he's like a [ __ ] water hose but
I don't think he wanted to be on her you
were just saying yeah so that he looked
like he had something he was aspiring to
but yeah he just he worked in a car wash
yeah no man it's it's it's it's it's
interesting it's like you know we all
have dreams but you didn't again it's
like you have to have again you know
they say kids it's like it's like it's
like the kids are like flowers you gotta
you gotta water them for them to grow
right so you got to give them that
confidence you got to give them besides
that you got to give them the tools like
you can't just be like oh
I want to be a rock star all right go
start learning how to play the piano
from A to Z you know what I'm saying
sure you can't just I think it's amazing
that you could you know pass by this
piano place and you played instruments I
think it's a I think it's unbelievable
to me that
a child could
get a trumpet in school have your dad
buy you a guitar have a piano that your
aunt who died since your piano and that
you could play that thing and sustain
and have a career at something by just
being in a room and just you know some
kids would just be in there forever and
you just create this [ __ ] business
for yourself isn't that crazy and you
entertain the world out of out of
isolation dude it's the craziest thing I
talk about that with my kids I tell my
son and and my daughter too but I go
guys I you know I don't know how like
this just happened and I go I get to sit
around and tell jokes and I've made a
living I've bought a house from it I've
done this I've done so exactly what you
just said and I tell them I go if you
could find something you love
I'm really like you know you you can
create your own you can create your own
uh um industry on yeah of course you
know what I'm saying where did where did
you where did you because you're
educated then usually usually you know
usually the comedians are not highly
educated you know they just they're just
kind of the the odd man I'll get you two
guys didn't make it you sit around
making fun of the [ __ ] night who made
it yeah
yeah and you just
align with somebody yeah you just become
like class clowns yeah how did uh what
what what is your earliest memory of of
comedy and of of what who got you on
that path yes so so what you just said
is true like a lot of a lot of comedians
start younger right so for me I've I've
thought about this a lot like when so we
come from Iran to America late 70s
settle in Northern California Marin
Tiburon is an affluent place but then
quickly the hostage crisis happens and
back then they start calling you [ __ ]
Irene in you know you know they start
beating you up all that [ __ ] right so I
remember they would beat you up in
school yeah I don't know if I got beaten
up by the way I know my friends I know
my friends got beaten up and I remember
a kid called me [ __ ] Iranian I
remember my pedals got stolen off my
bike yeah all kinds of stuff was
happening where I was like yo I got and
I remember getting in one fight and I
wonder if it had to do with that I still
don't remember because it was third
grade and we were fighting so much that
the bell rang and me and this guy was
still wrestling and the teacher came out
and goes what are you guys doing we're
finishing a fight get inside clean up
get inside so but I do remember sixth
grader calling me [ __ ] Iranian when I
was in the fourth grade and
um and and I remember a couple things
first of all I was good with sports
played soccer uh learned baseball you
know so so that helped on you know
kickball that helped right
um the other thing I used to do is I
used to bring a ton of candy to school
like we go grocery shopping back then
nobody knew oh don't get sweets and this
I go my mom would have one cart with
food I'd have one car with two Twinkies
ho-hos Starburst I'm telling you my
first foray into the American culture
was a Twinkie nibbling off the top and
licking that cream oh yeah I go what a
country man bad right you know and so I
remember I was I don't know they don't
ride on fire Twinkies yeah you could run
in there somebody said they're drinking
they don't it's all [ __ ] they don't
light on fire just have to wait we'll go
get it when they turn the fire off yeah
they're gonna be good so so so uh uh and
so so I used to bring Canada hand out so
I realized early on I was bribing my way
into friendship yes and then the third
thing I think was humor because as a kid
again back then
you know my parents they're upstairs
hanging out I'm downstairs watching you
know Woody Woodpecker Bugs Bunny uh Tom
and Jerry the whole hours hours you know
now we go oh no more screen time I'm
four hours man you know but you're doing
all that you're like oh this is funny
right then you then you graduate a
little bit a little bit later and then I
discover Eddie Murphy and I go oh [ __ ] I
go that's what I want to do you know and
I I have my tickets still from seeing
him live doing raw at the Oakland
Coliseum 1987 but even before that with
Delirious and even before that Eddie
Murphy the tape we would sit there
listening
yeah all that
where did they shoot you no what part of
your body not on the street yeah yeah
yeah uh that that tape from a club is
yeah it's what's called it's called
Eddie Murphy I think whatever it was
comedy isn't pretty yeah that's the one
where he also goes uh he goes he talks
about how cars are talking yeah you know
your lights are on your lights are on
somebody stole your back I said we go
get the [ __ ] he did he did that
on The Tonight Show yeah uh that one
that one's in a I had it in a cassette
yeah and
it was I think yeah and then Billy
Crystal had a cassette that was You Look
Marvelous because oh yeah that was
[ __ ] Look Marvelous amazing dude all
of that stuff I became this huge fan of
Comedy I'm sitting there I'm like whoa
what is this Steve Martin Steve Martin
and then the evening at The Improv I
think you had the Dangerfield specials
yep you discover Andrew Dice Clay Dom
Herrera was on there
um you got uh um uh uh Sam Kinison I saw
Sam Kinison at the Fillmore live when
phones were still on the wire and he
brought he'd bring that he'd bring the
guy up there yeah and he'd go tell me
what happened he goes well my wife uh uh
[ __ ] my brother
oh man there's there's a comedy I'm not
sure if it's still on Netflix but he did
it at The Wiltern yeah and at the end
he'd bring a guy on he did it out all
the shows yeah and the guy in The
Wiltern video is yelling into the phone
with Sam and I think he comes off the
ground he's so
animated he's letting it out yeah on her
and he it's just a crazy thing to see
that this guy probably wouldn't have
said anything and then Kennison had him
come up dial the number and he has that
voice hi is uh Sherry there yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
did a little Google yeah and uh he's
laying he'd [ __ ] you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I mean man the crowd's dying their
diets really he did he did that I
remember I remember those guys the dunes
there was a comedy store the dunes in
Vegas yeah in the late 80s and uh those
guys would be in there and he'd be there
and they'd be doing all that yeah yeah
and all of that stuff for me had the
influence but then coming from this
background of immigrant parents who were
like no you're not gonna do this like
because what I didn't imagine that they
would say yeah I think it's a good idea
no not at all and and the truth is so at
the age of 12 I did my first like
musical school I did a I did a play and
I got and I got on stage and George I
fell in love with being on stage I was
like this is it and I was good at it
because the lady I remember her name her
name was Shirley bomb bright who I think
she recently passed away she was the
director of the seventh eighth grade
play all right how long was the play uh
what was that what was the player oh the
play was called the boyfriend the
musical the boyfriend you know won't you
Charleston with me
we learned the Charleston wow and while
the band is playing that a rodeo though
I mean it's still in my head still in my
head 38 years later bro and uh and but I
was in seventh I was in seventh grade
and and the eighth graders had all the
lead parts and I was just like a
background dancer singer yeah and Miss
bomb right sat us all down before and
she goes listen when you're in a musical
there's like whether you got the biggest
part smallest part you got to show up to
every rehearsal
when you're dancing and singing in the
background you got to be smiling smiling
smiling
and I took that to heart and I think
part of that is being an immigrant kid
like I knew like if my parents says
something because you know like white
okay that's great advice it's a great
advice but but white kids in America are
always like you know no I you know [ __ ]
you dad you know what I'm saying yeah we
could like so when an authority figure
says to me smile that means I gotta
smile yeah I think that the white kids
are like who is this WOW right now so
for me I took it to heart so I remember
one day I come I show up
and his rehearsals and I was I was sick
I had a cold and I go over I go Miss
bomb right I'm a little under the
weather but I know you said we should
all show up so I showed up and I'll be
here I'll be singing and then okay no
problem so we start the rehearsal we're
singing and dancing I'm smiling I'm
singing and dancing she stops the whole
thing everybody stop stop
look at him she starts pointing at me
look at him and I'm like I I'm looking
around like me she said yeah he's sick
he's here he's singing he's dancing he's
smiling learn from him and I was like
whoa you still remember that too bro
took me to the other level I was like I
can do this and then after that the next
year I got the lead in little Abner they
put me same that same director was like
you're coming back you're gonna be Abner
and it was like the same with my my
parents would come
and the directors whoever that was
running it would always be like you know
your son's very talented he's got the
thing and my parents oh thank you and we
get in the car my dad's like that [ __ ]
is crazy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] is great
yeah [ __ ] is good so it did for a while
for like I got into plays I got into my
high school program uh my teacher there
I'm still in touch with her name is
Michelle Swanson she was like you got
the thing every teacher big you got you
got the thing like whatever that was I
was uninhibited you know I'm saying like
I wasn't on stage feeling this I was
about to say that that you you seem very
in control on stage and you know it's
it's uh it's poised that is not easily
learned yeah it's like it's like you
know they go can you teach can you teach
funny I go you could probably learn to
write some funny but to be honest you
know how it is man it's like people love
you on stage because you have this aura
that you're up there on and it's like
it's just what you're born with now but
also but also confidence but also if
you're a diver let's say you're a diver
yeah and you're like you would you you
would just have to let yourself go go in
whatever you do yeah because if you're a
diver and you're all everybody's diving
and then you jump and you're like I
don't think I and you you know you got
to believe it absolutely every time
absolutely I I call it I I I compare it
to surfing because I can only imagine I
I've tried surfing a couple times I'm
not I'm not that good as [ __ ] but when
those guys are in that wave they're
right in the way if you're the surfer I
laugh because I did try surfing one time
hold on and I thought I was gonna drown
oh yeah because I I couldn't get up on
the goddamn thing and all I do is fall
off but then I'm underneath the board
and I'm holding on because that would
stay afloat yeah and I didn't want to so
I'm holding on to that and I'm laughing
underneath the water yeah taking in
water finally get up and I'm still
laughing yeah because you had to be a
fat [ __ ] to get up there and people have
to be laughing at you and I did it for
an hour and I walked back in with some
board and the guy just said oh no who
give you that boy that boy too small you
need big boy
well Kelly you know we used to play in
the ATT Pebble Beach yeah and we would
do a 3M Challenge on Wednesdays and
at Sunset that fucker'd go out there in
a surfboard and surf right where we were
playing uh golf isn't that crazy I had a
picture of him it's in his soul he has
to do it I mean it's why like I said
during the pandemic I had to get in
front of people yeah I had to do it like
I couldn't I've talked to other Comics
who were like yeah I didn't do anything
for uh did you do anything during the
lockdown I could I couldn't I had to I
don't know what it is maybe I got some
deep psychological issue but I had to
like talk to people and get out in front
of people but then the thing but the
analogy was surfing comes in with you're
not thinking you just you just are
and that's in life like I tell my kids I
tell my wife listen the most the times
I've been the most charismatic with a
woman that's beautiful my wife was one
of them was when I wasn't thinking I
just started talking
the moment you start thinking yeah you
know how many times I was at like a club
or a bar and I see some beautiful girl
and I just kind of look and I look the
other way and I'd be like all right go
say hi and I know yeah no done gone yeah
you're done but the moment I go whoa and
my hands out and I'm talking
it it's always led to something good
similarly with stand up I think
or being on stage is this thing of like
I'm comfortable here and people feel
that you know I'm good I'm comfortable
I'm really like I this is my party I'm
running the party and by the way I know
that you've had this experience
you get to a point after several years
where it's like you know what I'm gonna
like I'm just gonna go off for a minute
[ __ ] all my material I'm just gonna go
talk to this person for a minute and you
just trust that's where the wave is you
just trust you start talking next thing
you know you're coming up with the
funniest [ __ ] you've yep and you reflect
upon you go how do I come up with that
but also like an officer if you hear
shots fired and you show up now your
senses are heightened yes now you hear
everything yeah now now where you would
just be in the same car driving down now
you're you're paying attention to
everything yeah and that's what we do
instead you go up there because it's
like it's like shots fired and then
you're up there controlling that whole
room yeah and you couldn't have that
same attitude of sitting down there
before no and then walking up there with
that you it would just be like a sieve
everything would fall out of it yeah
George has that ability you know I I
learned something like Goa go to the
Little America you know he just came up
with that on top of his head yeah the
g08 the Goa the uh um because he was he
was in a you know I love music have a
lot of guitars and stuff but I I'm not
very good at it uh but you wanted to
play they get that on like this and how
was your second lesson second lesson was
even better than the first one because
now he taught me you know a few more
notes and he said okay now watch what
we're gonna do and he started playing
rhythm
yeah behind me a little guitar with a
little
few chords and he says now you ready
a
B oh
B
C you know and E and D so I got five
notes and he's talking I got a sore
finger you know do you learn notes or
chords notes right now I'm hitting right
now but I I have the feeling that it's
going to turn into these are the notes
for this chord right these are the notes
for this chord and you'll be able to
play anything you want to play you know
I was a big um advocate of of
challenging people you know everybody
has something that they do because they
could do well where do you find it
whether you find it or not you it's in
there yeah you're not looking if you're
not going to look for you're not going
to find it yeah and you're like ah
there's nothing you know I do like to
draw and it's like well
then draw yeah then then do those things
because
it's
your [ __ ] life is tough man and that
find something in yourself that is it's
it's it's not anything you have to buy
or or control it's just there absolutely
and and and and and that's the beauty is
when you find that you don't have to be
the best at it it you know if you if
you're really good and you can go on and
make a living that's fantastic but if it
makes you happy
that's what this is doing and everything
at this point in time my life I'm 73
years old yeah
there is nothing that I have to do
nothing that is demanding for an income
because I have a retirement coming in
I'll never be rich I'm happy yeah I've
Got Friends I got family everything I
wanted to play was a lifelong it was a
beautiful dream yeah play this big bass
Mariachi guitar and now I'm taking
lessons for it well the reason I end up
doing this finally was because what I
was I kept flirting with it I kept
getting on stage getting off stage
getting off stage then my parents said
go be a lawyer then I went to undergrad
then I was like maybe I'll be a
professor I went to graduate school oh
[ __ ] and then I dropped out of that and
then I was actually at an advertising
agency working as an assistant and I was
doing plays on the side just having fun
doing plays and it was a comedy and
there was a guy there his name was Joe
Ryan this older guy
and he was in his 60s at the time and
Joe was one of these you know we have
guardian angels that come our way for
the time you don't know where they're
coming from but they find you Joe found
me and so he saw me making a dub of this
play I was doing for the other cast
members they wanted because I was
working an ad agency we had like a dub
room
and he watched he's watching he goes hey
miles you're funny and he was with this
guy who's always positive complimentary
to everybody
you're funny I go thanks Joe because
have you ever thought about doing
this for a living I go Joe you know my
Miss bomb bright told me to do it my
high school teacher everyone's been
telling me to do it
I said now I'm at the time I go I'm 26 I
go I'm going to work for like another
three four years save up some money and
at 30 I'm gonna go for it and he goes
can I talk to you for a second he took
me into his office and it's just what
you just said he sat me down he goes
listen Maz I'm in my 60s there were some
things I wanted to do in my 20s
but I just kept putting it off and I
never got to it he goes to if you really
want to do it do it
um that's an important for people that
are
listening and and I worked at I worked
in Northridge and I would walk across
the street to the Northwest Mall with
this guy Merle Richardson and he was in
the he was in the he was a he was in the
military
and we're walking to lunch one day and I
said hey Merle how long you've been here
he goes George I've been here now uh
uh
20
no
30 years
I go you don't know whether it's 20 or
30 people were walking I still remember
us walking in the sunlight but
Northridge and to eat and he said I got
out of the military I was looking for a
place to land for a year and I've been
here 30 years and that's when
I said I I gotta I gotta get the [ __ ]
out I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah I gotta I gotta I gotta move things
around and then I was working nights uh
in Van Nuys with my grandmother and uh I
would just be there by myself and I
would be like man I'm gonna do comedy
I'm gonna [ __ ] work at nights I mean
could you be could you be further away
from Comedy working at night I went in
there and this guy George Martin
and I said hey man I talked to you
George he was a cool dude and uh I
remember he's trying to quit smoking I
caught him and he's like yeah come on in
it
he had like he had like a quadruple
bypass oh God anyone supposed to be
smoking and I caught him and he's like
come in that's fine and then you know he
[ __ ] smoke would come out right there
and he told me I told him hey man I want
to do this
and I'm working nights I can't work
nights and do it I'm gonna have to be
and he said let me try to find you a
place during the day he says because
when I was your age I wanted to be in a
band and my friends all played and I
worked yeah they left me and they had
some success because so I know what
you're talking about yeah I'll find you
a place during the day and he found me a
place in this Workshop in the back and
that worked there how old were you
I was 19. I'd already done it I started
when I was 18. oh I just turned 18. I
went to The Comedy Store May 5th 1979 I
saw Danny Mora yeah Smirnoff Tim
tomerson
uh and Lois Broomfield and and and me
and my friend Ernie were still in high
school yeah and we were sitting there
going [ __ ] man this is what we got to do
it this is what we gotta do this yeah I
was I was lucky the the job that I did
uh because I had been on like 32 33
years uh already and I had to go to some
middle management school and I'm in San
Diego and you sit around the room the
instructor says uh you know like alcohol
get high I'm Gil kriel been on 32 years
I'm a lieutenant and so he came to me I
said go for real 32 years that's what
I'm doing and he said 32 years he said
you realize you're working for free
I said yes sir
he said no no I'm serious if not for
free damn close to it with the amount of
time you got on the apartment he
realized he could be retired I said I
understand sir
he said well my question to you is why
why would you be working when you could
be retired working getting the same
amount of money
I said correct me if I'm wrong at the
beginning of this this morning then I
hear you talking with some of the guys
in the class saying you just played in
the best golf tournament you had ever
played in only cost you 250 bucks to pay
playing it he says oh yeah he says I
love golf he says it was the best
tournament I've ever been in and I said
okay that's my point he said what's your
point I said you paid 250 do what you
love to do I'm doing it for free I love
what I'm doing there you go so I was
blessed I I I didn't want to know only a
detective could put that together that
fast I would have been like hey [ __ ] you
to come back the next day
that's funny yeah you know I would think
of [ __ ] it's funny when you when you
start doing comedy on the way home you
go oh forget it and then all of a sudden
you start to bring it closer to the
stage yeah yeah for the next day oh yeah
[ __ ] yeah well I would say I used to
watch Mooney and I was like I feel like
Mooney is who he is off stage on stage
and I realized will you explain Paul
Mooney to people who might not and
there's and there's CDs and yeah and
DVDs
um about as funny a person as as could
ever have it lived Paul Mooney was the
writer he wrote for Richard Pryor wrote
for Eddie Murphy he wrote for a lot of
uh homie the clown all that stuff Paul
Mooney was this amazing writer uh
amazing comedian he was angry but funny
and and handsome and handsome angry and
angry and he would get it and you and he
would always go up late because he was
always like yeah he was edgy so you're
gonna watch some edgy angry dude just go
out and and he'd be making you laugh and
then at some point he'd turn on you and
be like oh you find that funny and then
he would go off on you and you'd be like
what just happened but he was this
amazing person and
um and and and he said Frankenstein was
black because he never chase him through
the city
all right everybody's chasing him with
fire yeah as a little white girl [ __ ]
he's dancing with a little white girl
yeah there's still a pie off the
windowsill yeah I mean [ __ ] that you're
just like bad I mean he he he
I saw him one time and I picked him up I
was at the airport in the 90s
and he walks by me with his do-rag and
you smell cologne perfume you know like
Paul turns around you guys don't think I
said I said where you going he goes I'm
gonna go get a couch I'll drive you home
yeah and he gets in and he says have you
seen Amistad and I said uh not yet he
goes I watch it in reverse all the black
people go back down
let me tell you so he was so what what I
learned from watching him at The Comedy
Store was oh well you just said which is
the person off stage the longer you do
it the person off stays starts becoming
closer to the person on stage because
when you first do it you got this idea
in your head you're like oh I'm gonna be
whoever Eddie Murphy whatever but as you
do it more and more you're like no I'm
not everybody you start realizing and
then what you just said then you start
driving home and you're like oh that's
what I should have said they bring that
on and now you get more more comfortable
and that becomes that's you you know you
were one but you know it's just a it's
just a con it's just a road filled with
with
a consistency in an inconsistent
business like yeah like I remember at
the Laugh Factory in the 90s they would
do showcases they would be in there and
they'd be showcasing comedians that were
good and you're at the mercy of a
Wednesday night and maybe the crowd's
not good and I see people lose deals not
that they weren't funny they weren't
funny that night yeah yeah and that
night was just a night that was just not
their night and but instead of them
believing you were funny they had to
come and see you yeah after that I
already seen you then they'd bring more
people to see you yeah and then you
would work your way up I remember when I
was with Shapiro West and Dan Barnett at
rest her soul and
she may have told me the I think I said
it here nope she said to me on the phone
I said how come you know I can't get
anybody to come and see me showcase and
she was like nobody wants to see you wow
and she said sometimes you know you're
so embedded in your beliefs sometimes
you have to take a few steps backwards
to take a step forward and I'm like I I
don't think that's I agree with you
that's not listen you got to be true to
you and as a matter of fact I just I
just shot the special that I'm shopping
around right now I shot at The Comedy
Store
and it felt great it felt really good
and my agents and everybody showed up
and I had agents that hadn't been in my
shows in a while and they were coming up
going like wow that was great that
material could really translate into a
TV show and I'm like I've been doing
this [ __ ] for years [ __ ] where
you been yeah and the fact is it's like
it's but we keep doing it and we go
we believe in it I I you know you
sometimes forget like
people go oh what's your TV show let's
come up with a pitch I go okay and then
I think about I go wait a minute I've
been writing the show it's on stage take
the take the jokes you know I talk about
I talk about stumbling into the birds
and the bees with my kids this actually
happened
and I'm sure you guys probably have a
similar thing for the generations we're
from nobody did birds and the bees you
know what I'm saying the joke I do on
season go I thought I asked my Iranian
immigrant dad tell me about the birds
and the bees and go son we don't have
birds and bees we have lawyers and
doctors
you know nobody taught us any of that
[ __ ] but this actually happened I
stumbled into the birds and the bees
and this is like and and it's turned
into this bit but I'm just going to tell
you what actually happened was
you know trying to watch shows with my
kids my daughter was eight my son was
10. and I'm like what can we watch all
together and blackish the TV show
blackish yeah I go well that's a family
show you watch it dude everybody who's
listening to this right now just go on
Hulu or wherever you find blackish just
get the pilot episode the first episode
of the whole thing the father walks in
on his high school son who's about to
masturbate
so the high school son's about to take
his pants down underway down the dad
walks in he goes oh and he walks out the
Sun goes oh he jumps on the bed and this
actually all happened so I'm sitting
there with my eight-year-old and
ten-year-old and I'm and I see it and
you know how it is when you're sitting
with your kids and you're like I hope
they didn't they're not gonna know what
that was meanwhile I had read a book and
actually I have my my one of my sister
my sister is a psychologist he said if
your kids ever ask you a question the
best thing to do is be honest so in my
mind I'm like if they ask me a question
I gotta be honest now
my son is sitting next to me he's 10
years old he sees this scene he doesn't
even blink he's just he's my son I
always say boys are like spaced out so
my son's just SpaceX yeah yeah my
daughter she's eight years old right
away and girls my daughter's like CSI
FBI CIA she's like you she'd be a great
detector she sees everything right away
she goes what just happened
I swear and I'm like what what what do
you I'm like in my mind I'm like oh the
kid's about to masturbate but I can't
tell an eight-year-old so I go um
oh what just happened baby what just
happened okay this is what happened
um the dad walked into his room he's in
high school he's in the underwear he was
embarrassing so he walked out so I
tricked the eight-year-old she goes oh
okay I go thank God I just dodged the
bullet very next scene the father goes
to the mom he goes hey I just caught our
son playing with himself
I swear to God he said that ah you gotta
go watch the show and then my son again
clueless my daughter what does that mean
guys I started now my my sister's voice
is in my head now I'm realizing this
kid's really curious I swear to God I
start going what day I go baby sometimes
you know when boys are in high school
sometimes but they just they just
squeeze their pee pee just a little
squeeze I start saying that and my
daughter's looking at me like what the
[ __ ] and I'm go and I'm now I'm feeling
like a PR I feel like a modern proud
parent I've answered the questions yeah
sometimes girls just I'm sorry sometimes
boys just squeeze they just they squeeze
their people just a little bit I swear
to God she goes and then she goes did
you do it
man and this is all this so now I've
turned it into a bit on stage and like
that's a scene in a show you know what
I'm saying oh yeah totally so that's the
thing what I'm saying a pilot see in a
pot like we we lean you know what I'm
saying we we talk that's why we use this
about your manager you're like no I
gotta talk about me and my life yeah you
know when we went to when we went to uh
to Italy
uh
and would be when I was married and
would have the whole day lined out yes
for us so we're
in some City maybe Florence or something
and I'm halfway into a museum and I'm
like
like it's in a carb diet all the red
lights go on I go I'm I'm done yeah like
I'm done yeah well you gotta you can
only get out this way [ __ ] that I'm
going out this way and they're like you
can't go out that way sir I'm [ __ ]
going out that way and uh Mayan sees
these two dudes like one dude is on top
of another and their faces are in each
other's crotch and she says
she's standing there looking at it
because the guy's holding another guy
and she goes what's this and I'm like I
don't know they're just playing
horse playing
and she goes all good because they look
like they're blowing each other
come on
we went in Led Zeppelin we went out to
the indoor yeah yeah well get me the
[ __ ] out of here and she goes back to
the hotel and she's with her books and
she goes that was so unnecessary I bring
you guys here listen that that [ __ ]
statue is going to be here in a thousand
[ __ ] years yeah and I'm only gonna be
here till Tuesday yeah yeah I'm [ __ ]
I've had enough I've seen just every day
was mapped out I said why can't we just
sit somewhere and make fun of people
when they walk by yeah you know I you
talk about the birds and the bees and
I'll never forget
I'm down my mom's house now I had six
sisters no brothers
now my oldest daughter is 12 years old
about 12 13 right around there yeah and
my mom sits her and says sit down
because I want to talk to you yeah he
says but what she says I'm going to tell
you the real truth about the birds and
the bees right now oh [ __ ] and she says
oh gravity no you sit down right there
I'm going to tell you the stuff that
your mother won't tell you because she's
too nice oh wow and she's
what are you gonna tell me grandma she
says okay boys are going to promise you
gifts they're going to promise you love
they're gonna promise you a lot of
things but all they want is that [ __ ]
willow keep your legs closed don't let
them get to your left she says Grandma I
said no no no no keep your legs closed
all they want is that [ __ ] willow they
don't care about you they don't care
about anything they want the [ __ ] will
do you understand me my daughter's dying
she says yes yes and I'm sitting there
said go for it mom you know yeah
whatever it is so now my dad passes away
about seven years go by yeah
and I get to my mom's house and I asked
my wife because my mom used to tell my
wife everything but say but don't tell
me who yeah and she knew that my wife
was going to tell her so I get down
there and and I said what's up with my
mom she looks a little nervous she's
just she's going out with a widow or
right up the street a couple of doors
down his wife had been deceased for a
while his daughters went were friends
with my my sisters great it's just
they're going out to dinner and she's
embarrassed you she don't know what to
do I said hey Ma
I said so you're going out to dinner
with Sam she says I'm equal I didn't
want to go I didn't want to go up at all
he can't find I said Mom you've got a
lot of years left you were good and I'm
like that go out and have dinner enjoy
yourself I put yourself I said don't
worry about myself I'll take care of my
sisters
and my daughter looks up she says
grandma
remember
they only want one thing Grandma
the [ __ ] willow absolutely it's crazy
you know it's crazy because
I remember again in in doing my bit and
we're talking about all this like birds
and the bees I remember like a friend
this actually happened a friend of mine
seventh grade
his name's David he was walking home and
he found three bags grocery bags filled
with playboys and when I talk about on
stage back like I said I go back then I
go we didn't have these videos you get
to find that stuff and I go back then
people would pay it forward I go some
dude was done yeah he left it outside
he's like some boys are gonna find some
other pervert's gonna find this [ __ ] so
David gave me a bag of playboys and
that's like that was like oh my God like
that was like holy grail he goes he goes
You Wanna he goes like I found three you
want a bag I go of course I want a bag
took it home under my blankets whatever
under my mattress and that's you know
like that's where I learned to like
masturbate and all that stuff but it's
funny because I'm trying now because my
son's 14. I'm trying to talk to him
because we all know the guilt you felt
it is this age-old every guy after he
masturbates like I will never do this
again and [ __ ] I couldn't wait five
minutes later you're like I'm doing it
again so I've been trying I'm going in
so I'm trying I've been trying to talk
to my son about I've been like hey buddy
it's natural if you feel and he and now
he's he's 40 he's like Dad this is kind
of uncomfortable yeah what is it like
having a 14 year old boy
you know there's there's so many
emotions that happen because first of
all but also for this if it's a sweet
kid you know what's out there yeah
you're just like oh man you've got to be
detective man dude you know because you
know what's out there yeah sure and it's
just like maybe some kids aren't built
for
he's a well it's funny because
um first of all you have you know how it
is when you have a kid it's like that
that age where they're like pre-teen and
then teen is where you gotta you have to
stop parenting as much as you've been
right you make you've been making your
decisions their whole lives now they're
like now they want their own space so I
really push myself to be like all right
let him have his own space
um and then he had this one moment that
you're talking about
there was this girl I was pulling up to
pick him up he must have been seventh
grade eighth grade pulling up to pick
him up and uh and he's talking to this
girl and as soon as I came he kind of
like like they both separated really
really fast and he got in the car yeah
something's happening yeah so he gets in
the car and go hey buddy what's who was
that he goes oh just a girl this friend
all right then we're downstairs my wife
were watching my wife and I were
watching television and I go hey buddy
come down and bring the garbage cans
down and empty out the garbage you know
so he comes down empties out the garbage
and then he walks back up without the
garbage cans like you know the the
bathroom garbage cans and and I go I go
hey buddy where'd the cans go you put
them in the kitchen garbage can but you
didn't take the little ones back up oh
yeah I'm sorry and now he's walking
around the house like chicken with his
head cut off and and in all honesty at
first I was like is he on drugs that's
what I thought yeah yeah and I go hey
buddy you okay he's like yeah
I go what's going what's going on and I
go he goes and he's lost he doesn't know
where he's walking I go uh
uh I go hey man come here for a second
now I'm like getting and he's like why
why what's going on and now it comes in
my ear he starts Whispering he goes
remember that girl I go yeah he goes she
she asked me we have we have movie night
at school tomorrow she asked if I can go
with her and I was and he goes but don't
tell mommy mommy's sitting like two feet
away yeah I go buddy you got to tell my
mommy is going to want to hear this I go
and No One's Gonna judge you we love you
and now he's all nervous he starts
telling us and my wife couldn't be more
proud I'm proud we're excited for him
and then and then I go so what happened
she asked me to the movie and we go and
then he goes but I don't know what that
means because they're all watching it at
school
and I go well we don't know what that
means either like what does it mean and
he goes so what should I do I go buddy
just calm down I go this is what you can
do if you get up to go get popcorn ask
her if she wants popcorn sit next to her
just hang out just chill and this poor
kid he goes to school the next day and
he texts me from school he's like
um you know my friends told her you know
I guess her friends had told him that
she liked him
and then he and then they talked and she
said come to the movie and then enough
people found out where the girl got a
little hesitant yeah so my son texts me
like she just wants to be friends and it
broke my heart I was like oh and then I
was like I wanted to be like buddy
welcome to welcome to women you know but
I was just like hey pal it's all good it
was heartbreaking but it was sweet of
the same when I was in 10th Grade there
was a cheerleader
uh
huge tits tiny
yeah and she was the 10th grade you know
the JV uh and I liked her you know and I
hadn't really had a girlfriend yeah ever
I mean the the junior high was oh my God
I hope my whole childhood yeah
so in 10th Grade I meet her on a
Wednesday we we kiss on a Wednesday I go
to her house and watch TV on a Friday
Saturday
and by the next Wednesday her friends
had gotten into her head about me like
that dude's like so awkward and and I
remember we were going on a field trip
that Wednesday and she broke up with me
before we got on the broke up with me it
was like I don't think you know I want
to do that yeah and I was like
what the influence of their friends
and I get on the and I get on the bus
it's drizzling San Fernando High and
[ __ ] Fleetwood Mac well there you go
again
you want your freed that's it that's
plain where the [ __ ] we went to this
Museum of Modern Art and you so you're
leaving school and she just told you
that now you're in downtown are they
looking at some [ __ ] bones [ __ ] and
you get back to school you gotta go play
a game the next day that she's gonna be
at you know the problem is it's like
it's like you guys know how it is like
like when you used to go to clubs and
you would meet a girl and you guys are
having a great time but then her friends
were like we gotta go and you're like
we're having a great time now you take
that in high school you take that times
times a hundred they got voices in their
ears yeah yeah I remember the night the
night I lost my virginity
um my then girlfriend I was so excited
that I think I might have told a couple
buddies and I think they must have told
somebody so by the time the the school
day ended she comes over she goes you've
been telling people oh that we're gonna
like have sex tonight
and I came this close to not losing my
Virginia that night because I was like
listen let's forget them let's just go
out we've already planned like you
planned it I planned a date night so
we're gonna go see Tequila Sunrise with
uh Mel Gibson yeah and then and then I
had a book
I had an aunt uh who was living near us
who had this apartment who had agreed to
like let me go spend the night with my
girlfriend there so my aunt was gonna go
spend the night with my you know at our
house with my mom and me and my
girlfriend then we've been dating for a
while so I was like listen it's a
romantic night I I don't know if I I
might have told the whole family I'm
gonna throw the whole country of Iran
it's happening tonight you know we're in
the hospital
I got something to tell you come here
um but yeah it was all planned out and I
came this close to losing it because
like you just said everyone else is
getting in her ears I remember one time
we went to high school there's a park in
the same place and there was a center
field has got Leo Leo James yeah and
smoke is coming out he had a Cadillac
like a broom kind of like a very long
ass car and a little bit of smoke is
coming out of the crease of the hood
when you push it down yeah so so I tell
my friend Andy I go
is smoke coming out of [ __ ] Leo's car
and we're both standing there and we're
looking at the hood and it's just
a little bit where it could be
that he maybe he's got an oil leak and
the engine got hot it's smoking and then
Andy's like I think
I think it I think it's on fire okay I
said where we looked through the The
Raid you know through the the front of
the thing and the grill see a little a
little orange in there so it's class is
right there like we had he had a
architecture or drafting it was called
Drafting and I walked in and we go Leo
Leo and and uh this guy Mr Martin you
know Jazz dude he's like excuse me
excuse me young man you just can't walk
into my class and yell Leo like you know
Mr James is sitting there as a class
sitting there and anything you have to
say to Leo you can say to the class oh
my God I said Leo in the class your car
is on fire
by that time [ __ ] and my friends
watching I said hey [ __ ] move my
car
[ __ ] shit's coming out the sides see
that's a scene from a movie or a TV show
it's right there it's written [ __ ]
they don't think they watched my stains
off the back I couldn't move my car
because it was in the line I couldn't
get hey are you out of your mind I'm
trying to get in there [ __ ] move the
car I said the [ __ ] car blows up and
blow my [ __ ] car up so you could you
couldn't have written the Jazz creature
the way that that happened what you just
said exactly it's just like that's just
like it's beautiful
and all you're worried about is your
medical stained back seats
hilarious man Leo glass your car by that
time he walked out there and it was that
[ __ ] was engulfed in flames wow
wow he didn't take a shower and he
didn't do any carb maintenance he we
played a baseball game and he'd be all
sweating and [ __ ] he put his he'd put
his [ __ ] clothes on over his [ __ ]
baseball uniform [ __ ] man some of this
[ __ ] a double agent I said
[ __ ] take a shower man yeah he
never took a shower in school after we'd
stay there until [ __ ] 5 30 6 o'clock
[ __ ] around the characters man it was
the thing about it it goes back to what
I just said like it's it's this it's
this uh intense version of the the real
world you see people here and there but
there you've seen everybody every day
with everything with everything and
everyone's got something and you know uh
back then it's like I think about it
like everybody's living like my
grandparents were alive yeah yeah
everybody was alive all my foot you know
and it's that time when in the perfect
world nobody's passed yet yeah man
nobody everybody's in the world you're
right all your friends parents are alive
everybody's grandparents are alive and
every day is a great day yeah and you
graduate from high school
and we had a great summer in 79 and then
I remember the first day of school when
I woke up and you don't go to you
haven't got the first day that there is
no school isn't that weird and I was
laying back there that house it was kind
of drizzling and [ __ ] I was like
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] am I gonna do now
that's what that's actually one of the
things I think that causes like you know
a lot of times like people young people
get
bipolar or depression in their late
teens early 20s because it's the first
time you haven't been on this treadmill
that's making you go I didn't
and you know whether you chose to learn
or not yeah it was I never had a bad
time in school I wasn't the smartest kid
but you had your friends there you had
girls there you had baseball yeah we you
know it was all social it was so great
man yeah I
my parents would go to
parent counseling you know my dad always
said let's talk you know and same thing
every time you got to try harder because
everybody said the same thing hey he's
got the intelligence she's smart he's
just lazy here you know I didn't care
about school it's all about social it
was all about friends
like when I came back from the Army I
thought my I was embarrassed because
except for my transcripts because now I
wanted to go to college yeah and I
obviously thought D stood for damn good
I was embarrassed when you when you came
back from Nam and you see those guys
that I mean they're not as time goes but
I I think you could probably see a
family member and not have the reaction
that you would have seen somebody that
was with you in nam
oh yeah yeah I guess it's a much more
much more emotional for me
to see those guys tell them about the
guy you saw in the in Arizona there was
a a captain that I flew with uh when I
first went from inserting troops in
medebag and do all this stuff just get
on gunships where all you're doing is
going out and shooting up you just
killing yeah and my first flight was
Captain Tom stemke uh
we went on a gun run and so we're
shooting and my gun got jammed and you'd
make a daisy chain you come back around
you got to be ready to go again well I
wasn't ready to go again because it was
still jammed yeah and when the third
time around I'm ready I'm hot and we go
when I come down this guy came up and he
chewed my ass I had never been chewed
out like that yeah before and nor have I
ever been shoot out since then yeah and
he got dead in my ass saying that I was
an integral part of you panicked you
died you need to stay with us we need
you
so he walked away and I I said
everything he said was right
so I learned immediately you know what
my flaws were and what I had to do and I
always wanted to hook up with that guy
you know he he left Vietnam I left
Vietnam
and then
I was told he went through PTSD got to
him so he went on the down low yeah
had a rough life and I kept asking for
him finally I got a call hey he wants to
talk to you call him up well he's come
out of his low life Wow
and I talked to him and we reunited he
he tough life short version he'd he went
into the army because him and his dad
had gotten into a physical altercation
Wow broke some bones on his dad he
whipped his dad and he he left had to
get away
went through the Downs he was about to
commit suicide and decided to go to
church with his wife one time this is
all I was laughing at her I said okay
I'll go this last time I'll go with you
and that was a day that changed his life
so first thing he did was he called up
his dad and he told his dad daddy I'm
sorry I apologize I love you I'm begging
for forgiveness and his dad just told
him son you don't have to beg me for
forgiveness it's everything's done and I
love you he talked to him he says Daddy
I'm gonna go see his dad was in the
hospital his daddy I'm gonna go see you
his dad died two hours later oh but it's
like that's all he was waiting up for so
now all this time goes by
I'm going to be lecturing in Phoenix
he's going to go on vacation he's going
to be in Phoenix for Michigan
uh a friend of the family who is a news
director at NBC the NBC affiliate in
Phoenix
says hey would you mind if we film this
they're big on this stuff in Phoenix you
know two old veterans like
contact hey yeah
do it so they did it and I saw him for
the first time in 53 years wow and we
cried like babies of course we just it
was so emotional to see him
uh because he helped get me back alive
wow and he would say the same thing I
helped him okay but but he was a leader
he's a great man and it was just it's
funny that it's funny to me that you
know people expect that in families but
I think it's more
I think I didn't have much of a fan but
I think it's more maybe more prevalent
in some people when they go through
something like like that yeah that's
good life-saving you know this was life
or death and then and he did it and we
made it and and he
I another pilot that I flew with in
Vietnam just happened we we saw each
other even find out we live in the same
city today wow and the first time I
bumped into him and my wife was me I
said come here you got to meet my wife
and my family he came over and he
started crying and we both started
crying and he just said you don't
understand
I never knew if we were going to make it
out alive yeah we're here and the last
thing I ever thought of was how to have
the opportunity to meet the family wow
and so it was very because that was true
uh
that was true love I mean you you needed
each other that was my brother that was
both of my brothers
it's funny what becomes a trigger you
know when mine was like in Little League
and you know it's t-ball and it's
there's no you know there's no Peril
there's no risk and there's kids playing
t-ball
and then the next year they got a little
more serious and there wasn't this one
for girls to be with the other guy but
we went to the driving range they had
the the party with the whole team yeah
and then they're signing baseballs and
she was in the car seat and
you know she's like Daddy look you know
they gave us a baseball and I look at
the baseball and you see all the kids
signatures and I said
never forget your first coach or your
first team I was crying yeah and I was
like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah you know
because I loved being part of a team
yeah only child that those a team to me
meant family yeah sure which I didn't
have at home yeah but just holding that
baseball and seeing those those names on
them I teared up the other day two days
ago you said on your balls again I sat
on my balls I got a message
from a family that was one of the first
murders I handled back in 1981. wow and
I got very close with the family matter
of fact I was invited to one of the
weddings and uh one of their kids
weddings and uh that was an early on
murder and I remember I was third wheel
two other investigators because I was
new I was learning but I wanted to do
all the work I wrote search warrants I
put in the time and the effort and those
guys one was on his way out and the
other one hated to be there anyway so I
I did this and now here 40 some years
later
they're still reaching out and who was
it it was uh a
uh family from Baldwin Park and he got
killed on their 25th wedding anniversary
the husband did and the son uh Tommy
Cardenas he was shot and he had been a
former Explorer for Baltimore Police
Department they shot him because they
thought he was a cop
and both his lungs collapsed they were
able to save his life they shot him
multiple times but the family was a
beautiful family
and my heart just went out to him I gave
him every every bit of energy that I had
we solved the case we convicted the guys
uh the judge in that case that piece of
[ __ ] uh the jury convicted the the guy
of first degree murder and the judge
sentencing day reduced it from her first
to a second because he said he felt the
jurors dealt with her with her hearts
and not with their minds which was
absurd for him to do that and I just
told the wife I remember calling a local
friend of mine with the press and I said
I can't tell you this but if you call me
back up I can tell you what happened in
the courtroom today because I can't give
you the so he called he says hey what
happened again I told him
the next day two days later
they had pictures of the judge front
page and what he had done to the family
why did he do that
was it just the way he judged I have no
idea I have no idea I had people ready
to protest the court they were ready to
go out there and pick it it was a wrong
thing how many years did the guy get
though the guy that killed him well then
they uh because he did that and because
they appealed the case it got overturned
his his oh his everything so now it's
getting ready to go back they're going
to retry the guy oh wow and instead of
fighting it he pled guilty he played out
so he got a long term wow for what he
did
but that was my first case and 40 years
later the family's reaching out and
still remembers you know how what we did
and how it went isn't it amazing that
you know like you know he gets a lot of
a lot of stuff from like
you know Night Stalker groups or clicks
that you know they're like hey the wrong
one died I mean you know where somebody
you have a guy who's a [ __ ] demon who
really looked like a [ __ ] devil in
that in that special where he's not
wearing a shirt and his bones are
sticking up and yeah he's got scratches
on his body yeah
Maddie that's what I look like without a
shirt on doesn't matter if you could see
that [ __ ] in the in the middle of the
night where you're not expecting it that
guy you know that guy's in your house
well that's like with the Dahmer the
Dahmer Netflix thing like a lot of
people coming off of the Dahmer Netflix
thing a lot of people were like watching
it and going like oh I like this guy you
know they yeah they like Dahmer and you
go he was eating people yeah you know
[ __ ] eating people and putting them
away like leftovers but but that all
goes back together
tortillas that all goes back to what you
were saying about like being judged on
your material and stuff when you realize
that there's a lot of crazy out there
and you go no matter what you say and do
everyone's gotta be back in the day if
people had opinions they had to write
you a letter yeah you have to open it up
or the comedy club would leave a [ __ ]
thing on the on the desk tell us what
you think of what it could be like oh
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] yeah but now they
just write it they just write it on
Twitter or wherever it is and so when
you realize the level of crazy that's
out there that's when you gotta go you
know what I'm just gonna let this go be
because because as you just said
someone's going to go and you know
idolize the killer well that killer is
whatever you know or the lady who
married the Menendez remember she was
representing the Menendez she married I
mean it's crazy out there but they get
they get they're I I mean it's I don't
think I would
I mean as a baseball player I don't
think I was gonna
[ __ ] hang around with some dudes that
were all black you know and with Nine
Inch Nails t-shirts and all that other
[ __ ] like my grandfather was like
yeah yeah if I would have dyed my hair
he would have taken me and washed it and
shampooed it till all the diet came out
but that's also that's also where you
come from like again that that goes back
to the Immigrant background stuff too
it's like I I feel like a lot of times I
I worry like I never I didn't get high
or do any of that stuff going through
high school because I feared my parents
wrath you know what I'm saying like I I
think that it's good to fear your
parents you gotta love them it's good to
fear them because you got you gotta have
that thing of where like when the kid
that one kid in the car was like hey
let's all try some of this blow and the
other one goes my dad would [ __ ] kill
right and I want my kids to know that
I've told them that I go you show up
with that [ __ ] I mean there was a great
scene I think it was a movie was called
I like it like that I think that was
what it was they're they're a good movie
yeah great movie right is that the one
where the the Puerto Rican dad gets in a
fight with the Mom they're arguing and
the son steps up to the and the sun's
like 10 years old I think that's what
this is yeah I think it is it sounds
like 10 or 11 years old and he steps up
to the dad he's like Dad you know don't
talk to my mom like that and he goes oh
oh you're oh you're a little big man
okay okay
um you wanna be a man okay
um who bought you those who bought you
that shirt
and he goes and the kid you see the kid
starting to melt and he goes uh you did
okay can I give me get my shirt back
because you're mad now you could be
wrong yeah give me give me the shirt wow
who bought you the pants and and this
Dad and and it breaks my heart as I'm
talking about this but at the same time
the lesson that like this dad taught
that kid
he's like he basically gets the kid to
take all of his clothes off and he goes
whose house is this who pays for the
house and he goes you do all right he
opens the door they're like in a car you
know apartment in New York he puts him
outside the door and he closes the door
so now the kids in the in the hallway
naked now that's heartbreaking but at
the same time the lesson that kid
learned right there was to fear that Dad
now again I don't know if it's good or
bad or whatever but like the Dad gives
it a few beats and then he opens the
door he goes you ready to come back in
and the kid goes yeah and he brings the
kid back in and there again there's
nuances to this right I'm not condoning
kicking your kid out and making him
naked but I am saying that if I said to
my kids if I see you like you know
showing up with some [ __ ] white
powder
yeah I'm you know good luck on the get
get the [ __ ] out of my house you know
like you know when I was when I was a
senior that we had a band play uh right
outside the auditorium for lunch and me
and my friends were already drinking
like before lunch you know we're [ __ ]
hammered and we're watching this band
play You Know cover tunes and they said
hey don't you have a don't you have an
interview at Sears in Northridge at 2
30. I'm like [ __ ] yeah man my girlfriend
worked at Sears I thought she was
already out of school I was a senior
you're gonna go I go man I gotta go I
was [ __ ] I was hammered man like
hammered so I drive in my ghost down
there to the Northridge I go in there
I'm sitting in the chair in the
Personnel department and it's like when
they put you in those rides where they
flip it and you just keep going around
in circles I'm sitting there but I'm
spinning oh I'm spinning them in the
chair like I'm going around and around
and I said uh how much how long is it
and she's like how long is what
your interviews in 15 minutes you're
early and I'm like okay I'll be back at
one at like 1 30. and I'm [ __ ]
spinning man and it's
you know in the middle of 1 30 215
whatever
I lay down I [ __ ] woke up it was
already dark outside oh I slept for six
hours in that [ __ ] car in the front
seat I got up and you know you lean up
and you're like it's where the [ __ ] am I
oh God I was in a parking lot I saw the
sign Sears I was all all the cars were
gone and I woke up in their [ __ ] six
hours later man [ __ ] and I caught [ __ ]
from her for missing you missed your
appointment yeah well you know I was
there but yeah yeah I'll sleep in the
car so I was close [ __ ] I slept in
the [ __ ] car forever I should have
kept that car and just slept outside in
that [ __ ] thing I don't sleep for six
hours in a row
but I wouldn't want I wouldn't want mine
to have had my childhood you know we
gave her a few obstacles but I think it
may it may I don't know man as kids you
know what they hold on to yeah uh but I
don't think I would have changed very
much of mine like I had fun with the
guys I I grew up with you know and even
though it was painful it is growing up
it's painful
and that's what that's what gives you
the stories and the knowledge and the
and also the uh perspective you know I'm
saying like it's like it's you know I I
you know I I look we've we've we've all
had a lot of great things and a lot of
bad things you know and you can't
imagine if you only had good things
one time they would you know that
somebody had a pool and you know we
didn't have [ __ ] bases and go on your
underwear because there's only going in
my underwear so you're going underwear
that's where I got that joke where the
Underwood and my grandma was like pull
the front
she's like pull the front the front of
what my audience yeah yeah of course
yeah yeah yeah and and that's all she
did watching the kids swim pull up front
hilarious pull it out there get a little
get a little room in there dude I
remember my dad my dad used to I I went
my mom used to take me clothes shopping
I hated it my mom would be like try this
on try that out I tried it on she'd be
like all right we're gonna go across the
street might be cheaper and we'd be I
mean like eight hour eight hour process
I hated it one time with my dad large my
dad you know baller baller walks into
Nordstroms he goes what do you want I go
I don't know how about that shirt that
and that it goes all right what's your
size here goes to the lady hello young
lady give I still said that for him give
this this oh my God and give it for me
same thing large
he got
whatever I pointed out he's like just
give me the same [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
hard and it was like it took 10 5
minutes 10 minutes we're done so give me
the same thing but but he was a big
sweatsuit guy again they're very they're
very like what kind of sweats you like
like Sergio takini Fila you name it so I
had this feeling I had this I had this
Fila like a a baby blue Fila sweat
sweatshirt combo I see it all right and
and one day I woke up I didn't have
clean underwear so I go I'm going
underwear list imagine this 16 years old
no underwear
I'm walking down the hallway
I got the biggest heart on I get I'm
just I'm holding a tent right there and
I'm just like oh and I'm like people and
it was one of those things you pulled
the front pulled the front of me think
of that because I was like and I'm
trying to think so are you trying to
think thoughts because you can't because
now kids are walking by you can't be
like grabbing your crushes like you're
thinking thoughts of like you know the
Dead Rabbits and you're just trying to
think of thoughts to bring it like just
calm that but I'm walking through I mean
I was like saluting everybody when when
we had baseball practice and there's
outside of Laurel Canyon there and I was
at third base and and I saw my
girlfriend drive by she had a Toyota
like GT and my dick got hard I said oh
there might be future taking infield you
know you see your car she honks but I
can see her car yeah
[ __ ] man it's also the
um I probably should say this but but
when we were 19 we said hey if we're in
our 50s I mean when you're 19 think
about when you're 19 or 20 and
we said if we're in our 50s and we're
not with anybody
we should reconnect and spend the rest
of our lives together it's like Harry
miss Sally and I'm not with anybody and
I invite her to a show at the Forum and
then you know she came back everybody
came back to my house and she's like
remember the pack that we made and I
said
the pack that we made was when and when
we were 19.
yeah I was 20 you were 19. I said you I
uh about us being together like in our
50s that was a long time ago she goes
well you're not with anybody I said but
you're married and she's like say the
word and I'll [ __ ] here
well what word is it because I'm going
to want to [ __ ] say it by accident
hilarious and I think I think
um
she moved to Florida but I think if I
were to say to her
leave your husband and come and live
with me yeah soul mates yeah but uh just
honk your horn one time pull up front no
I'm not gonna I won't be doing that [ __ ]
oh man it's it's an exciting time that's
when you asked me about my son it's like
I success I'm excited for him and I'm
sorry for my daughter too you know it's
you like everything's everything's new
man everything even even old is new like
new listen man every day is a gift yeah
and every day is a chance to be better
or to just but be it's better to be than
to have been yeah yeah but but we
definitely are like the like the Yodas
to them to their Luke Skywalker you know
it's like a lot of times you see them
doing something and you're like yo let
me just tell you real quick you know
what you're doing and I would say yeah I
know what I'm doing and I [ __ ] didn't
know what I was doing hilarious but I
didn't want to tell him I didn't know
what I was doing yeah yeah of course no
you think you think you know I mean
that's the age-old thing like every
every age you're at you think you know
I've even even like recently he was
going to some trip with the school and I
was like buddy take this jacket they've
said bring the extra jacket I don't need
it just put it in your goddamn backpack
see what happens and then when he comes
back goes you know what you were right I
go I know I was right my son is 44 years
old I've hated since he was a kid all he
ever said was I and I tell his mom I
still Turtle a day I said I tried to
tell my son something he says I know
that I know Dad
to this day I know yeah well God damn it
if you know why do you do this yeah
but it's part of us for us to let go too
like I talked to my wife about that a
lot I go and I gotta check myself
sometimes like just let go
let him learn what part of you are you
like your dad
I think I try to be generally I learned
generosity from my father for sure
um and and and taking you know I've
actually been fighting this now where
he he taught me to take care of
everybody
you know what I'm saying like like take
care of everybody and then I realized
I don't care how powerful you are you
can't take care of everybody and what
was your grandfather you remember your
grandfather is Father
um no not his father I never met his
father because his father passed away
before I was born but my grandfather
from my mother's side was this like salt
of the earth like a Gandhi type like he
was another person who was he lived with
us he was one of the closest people to
me so my grandfather was just this
that's pretty cool man yeah man his name
was Akbar farzana and he was this dude
he'd wake up every morning because you
know think about it he was born like
probably 1903 1905 we didn't even know
what year uh in Iran we don't know what
year because no that's the thing like I
used to do a joke about like every once
in a while with someone else's birthday
we just throw him in we were like it's
your birthday so he's like all right but
but back then in the you know the world
he grew up in like you know when you
wake up you you know there's no baggy
pants there's no holes in jeans he used
to wake up every morning three-piece
suit Fedora right and then he would he
had nothing to do tired he was living
with us he'd get on a bus take the bus
down to like the uh to the market get
fruits blah blah blah food come back
cook once in a while you get up clean
the whole kitchen he was this guy that
really like you know you I learned a lot
from so that was my grandfather from my
mother's side yep and then from my and
and he was just kind he was a good human
being and then my dad like I said my dad
was just like
there for everyone a story I thought
about my dad so my dad he had uh he had
uh was it three or four brothers and two
sisters but he was the oldest son
and he worshiped his mother because he
lost his dad at a young age right
so when he lost his dad in this
patriarchal culture back in Iran in the
whatever it was 40s or whatever 50s he
had to like he had to step up and be the
man right so he goes from one town in
Iran uh called Tabriz to Tehran
and he he starts you know getting into
this he starts becoming successful at a
certain point he's super successful so
all of his brothers are working under
him they have this electric company one
of his brothers is uh um this guy who
without telling the family he marries
this woman and has two kids with them
with her but he doesn't tell the family
because she comes from like another like
another class where she he feels he'll
be judged so he's got a secret family on
the side
meanwhile he's working for under my dad
for this company so they send him to
like the let's say like the offices in
Big Bear or something you know two-hour
drive so he goes there
he gets a call from his wife one day
like earlier in the morning going hey
one of your kids one of our kids is like
has a fever come back so he gets in his
car at like two three in the morning
whatever it is starts driving back to go
see his sick kid windy Rhodes Back Then
basically drives off a cliff and this
goes this goes to what I say when you go
no matter how powerful you are
you can't control everything right so my
father told the story of like back then
he was so powerful that he could like
Charter a plane he goes I get I get a
plane with my friend who's like you know
the general of whatever the army or
whatever we get this private plane we're
gonna go fly to this you know far off
place where you know you you got to get
there fast you you know you you take
hours right and he goes before I leave
he goes my mother I mean my grandmother
his mother grabs his arm and goes
whatever you do keep my son alive
and he goes okay and like he took that
upon himself and he goes I landed this
like far off place in the mountains and
he goes I see my brother and he goes he
had had such a bad accident his head was
the size of a watermelon and he goes he
was in the bed in the hospital and he
had like a hundred and five hundred six
degree fever like he was gonna die and
he goes I went to the doctors and back
then again my dad people knew my dad
right because I went to the hospital
stuff I go you keep my you keep my
brother alive I'm gonna [ __ ] all you
guys up so he goes next thing you know
the doctors everyone's just pouring ice
into this bed and just bringing his
fever down
so he saves the guy but this poor guy
the rest of his life like half his body
was paralyzed
and he lived the rest of his life the
only thing he had to look forward to he
would just have a drink or two every day
he was like you know he had alcoholism
too but he had but his life was
miserable yeah so I tell the story all
the time I go this guy tried to control
everything he tried to save his brother
because his mother said save my son yeah
but even he couldn't like this other guy
had a miserable life so what's the point
exactly yeah you know yeah you got to
let it go you know I was driving out to
uh the house out of out of L.A and you
know I have this the cars that have like
the
low high performance tires are low
profile yes and
uh I was in one car and it had the guy
it had a the tire was busted on the
inside and he said to me I don't know
how you I don't know how this tire
didn't blow up on you man wow I don't
know how you're I don't know how you so
it happened again
in another car
and
I got there and when I came out the tire
was flat it's brand new tire it had a
huge [ __ ] Spike through it man
and uh I went and got a car that
has tires like you can ride in the like
like tires you won't have to worry about
performance yeah and because I I feel
there's an instinct in me that one time
two times yeah
they're not going to be a third time
yeah yeah and that car is probably not
built with those tires to go that far
because of what's on the road yeah and I
mean you're driving 90 miles an hour and
you blow out you're gonna you got no
chance again you realize like I don't
care who you are Steve Jobs was the
richest man in the world he got cancer
he died so you realize he was happy he
was having a yacht built by hand all
wood and he was gone and then they go
hey your boat's ready and it was just
this beautiful thing yeah and he
couldn't you can't control that and I
feel
I feel like I was going down the road
yeah of something that would have been
bad for me yeah like a blowout on the
highway yeah been four or five in the
morning yeah I'm glad you recognized it
yeah yeah absolutely man all right
modest yo thanks for having me man
welcome for pleasure yeah pleasure
pleasure
um my my uh jeez uh I'm I'm still
touring if anybody follows me at Maz
giobrani on like Instagram and all that
I've been talking about the protests in
Iran now yes so what's going on in Iran
so what happened was so you know it's
interesting like two three months ago I
was a comedian now I become like an
activist right because what happened was
so what I told you guys earlier when
there was a revolution 43 years ago the
Ayatollah Khomeini comes in for 43 years
it's been the Islamic Republic of Iran
which means women have been oppressed
lgbtq have been oppressed religious
minorities have been oppressed and the
people of Iran the young people of Iran
have been suffering under this regime
and so just a few months ago there was a
young girl named Massa amini 22 years
old walking down the street her hair was
out of her hijab just a little bit the
morality police showed up arrested her
and in the process killed her and that
led to protests and now these protests
have been going on for two three months
they've killed at least 400 or so people
they've imprisoned thousands of people
and it's an oppressive regime and it's
like I was I warn Americans I go don't
mix religion with politics because
that's what we end up with you end up
with a morality state that tells you
dress like this do this do that do that
um so and even still now mom's like in
this westernized civilization like they
still are well think about I mean like
like the fact that they took away I
don't care where you stand on abortion
whether you're Pro or anti whatever but
the fact that you took the a woman's
Choice away after 50 years right so we
should be able to choose similarly with
the hijab if you want to cover yourself
great if you don't don't but this regime
is is so uh oppressive and they and they
execute people and they like they've
really and they're corrupt so a lot of
times these guys who are up top and were
like God said this that the other yeah
they're like God also told me to take a
couple million yeah and funnel it off
they have they have children living in
the west it's it's a really I mean as
somebody who is
privileged to live in the world that we
live in I felt like I had to I had to
express you know use my voice of course
no so my whole page but you know what
man it's it's a it's not an easy Choice
uh to do that I mean it seems easy to be
able to stand up for what you believe in
and what you your of your country but
also with the way social media is yeah
you got they're vipers yeah everywhere
and people that would just have it have
their sense be to bring you down
absolutely as a matter of fact people
were like attacking a little bit and and
what I realized quickly I was like I
just gotta I can't even engage them no
no no I gotta stay the course you know
uh Public Enemy had a had a song uh He
Got Game and there's a line in there
that some basically it says something
along the lines like [ __ ] the game if it
ain't saying nothing and I've always
been someone who feels like you got to
say something I'm saying we have to say
something you know Richard Pryor right
again Muhammad Ali Colin Kaepernick I'm
always always ways very much a proponent
of saying something even you and your
comedy right you're saying something
you're calling people out on their [ __ ]
and so if you're not what's the point
you know so for me
um when they say say nothing be nothing
yeah that's it say nothing be nothing
right yeah but but I I've been actually
I've been going to school that's heavy
that's heavy man that's yeah I mean
politics here are one thing but politics
of you as an American
um
Iranian is a nut it's another that all
that stuff over there is do you feel
endangered for doing this by you know
it's funny Gil you asked that it's funny
because because I've been doing a bit
you know as comedians we're always
working you get a death threat you're
like oh this is a good bit yeah so
I I've been doing this bit about how
growing up and this is true like the
generation of my parents and maybe even
my own generation there was this fear
that was instilled in Iranians around
the world yeah and this comes from any
immigrant that comes from a com from a
country where you know they were
oppressive where my parents would be
like don't talk don't talk about them
right like don't talk about them they're
gonna come for you who they who's they
them who is them and I was like I'm in
the sixth grade in Northern California
who's coming after me yeah so that was
in my head right now I'm seeing any run
these these listen dude the women the
young people they don't give a [ __ ]
they're walking towards the bullets
because they've had enough so when I see
that I go these guys so I went online
this is actually true I went online
um once the protest started I posted
right away I go I support the people of
Iran I'm with the people of Iran
masamini was killed we need to support
these young people that want their
freedoms I'm with you so I posted it my
aunt calls me up what are you doing I go
what they're gonna come after who they
who's they them and then wow she was so
she says this I happen to be on tour in
Europe I'm in Germany doing shows and I
forgot to put the do not disturb sign on
my hotel room I swear to God the next
morning the next morning after my aunt
was in my head the [ __ ] cleaning lady
comes into my room seven in the morning
she opens my door she starts coming in
you've never seen me jump out of bed I
thought I thought it was them
and she's like I'm like what and she's
like it's okay and I'm like who are you
and she's like I'm the cleaning lady I
was like [ __ ] and I realized my aunt had
gotten in my head you know and I and I I
I and I say in the in the the joke I do
is and this is true I I call her up I go
listen I'm sure I'm on an enemy's list
but I'm like number ten thousand they're
gonna set them this is an intern you
know I'm saying he's gonna be sitting in
the back of the comedy club being like
this is not a bad place to be you know
yeah so anyway all that to say I
honestly like sometimes I fear like I
feel like all it takes is one night job
but at the same time I go dude I gotta
be like I would rather I'd rather say
something and have that threat than not
say something and feel like I I you know
thank you for what you do on behalf of
the Iranian people I appreciate it I
appreciate you man I I went viral I
can't I can't oh I think I've made a
something against a leader and I live
alone and every night I thought they
were going to come in and put a
suppository on my
[Music]
Googles
to wake up oh he died naturally
naturally you know [ __ ] man
it went through my hand man it goes
through our heads of course it is
because they're gonna [ __ ] get it
first of all I'm not gonna hear him get
in well you have dogs that I [ __ ]
misted those dogs yeah yeah yeah these
guys are trained to do this [ __ ] they're
from the animal rescue anyway hilarious
well when you see that that guy that
jumped on stage with Chappelle you're
like that guy was not a Navy SEAL that
guy was just an idiot the fact that he
got was able to get into the into the uh
the knife yeah and and to get into
Hollywood Bowl and like to get him for
like when you see that you really don't
need to be that that train to to go
after somebody you go man if that's the
case man you know I think for as much as
people believe that they're safe it's
it's still very primitive our safety
yeah yeah of course you know I live in a
place where when I pull out there's a
there's a a brick wall there yeah and
somebody could be standing there yeah
with a black thing on it Pat and they
just dropped the gun and get on a
[ __ ] bike yeah and go downhill and be
gone man it's like you know it's it's I
would I would say
that if you feel safe
there's people who feel safe and there's
people who make sure they are safe yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah we're one
of the ones that makes you ever safe
whenever somebody watching
hey or you get run over by a car you
know that's an ugly accident you know I
talk about that too because we all get
scared about this that the other and I
go you can be worried about one thing
you'll be walking down the street and
that freaking tree is just gonna fall
right on your head oh yeah that's all it
takes this guy in the motorcycle and up
in Malibu the truck rat you know there's
an accident right in front of him and
the truck came and hit him and they
thought he was gonna die and he's alive
eight days later you know he's alive and
well he was doing nothing more than
sitting on his motorcycle at a red light
he was riding a motorcycle uh oh
um Alonso yeah so
I was telling him like I love
motorcycles I think they're great yeah I
wrote One in a movie I wouldn't know I
want to own one but I never would
we were playing golf in Malibu with the
Malibu Country Club Going up Canaan Road
and
there's a lot of dust we're coming up to
coming up Canaan there's a lot of dust
and we look and there's a guy over there
and he's laying face down his motorcycle
is probably like 50 yards ahead of him
[ __ ] and it's still on a tire spinning
there's all this smoke and he's laying
there chest down and his head is turning
like this like just you know his
helmet's on and he's laying flat out and
his head's just turning like this
and in the middle of the street about 50
yards behind him is his [ __ ] leg from
the knee down oh still in the boots
still in the [ __ ] man and I'm like and
we just came and we were golfing we just
came up on it and we're like I don't
give a [ __ ] if they gave me a bike every
day yeah I wouldn't ride one of the
street it's so dangerous bro I was I was
driving down to the La Jolla Comedy
Store one weekend and there was a little
Bumper to Bumper you know I was Bumper
to Bumper and I I I tell myself
something to go don't complain because
back I mean you know you don't know what
it is it's all in the universe anyway
yeah and I'm driving and then all of a
sudden I see the motorcycle and the and
the the tarp was over the guy he's dead
and that and in my mind I'm like now I
gotta go tell jokes but it was it was
crazy we were in the car you know I was
telling the guy that was driving me for
Blue Beetle in Atlanta you know it's
like yeah I'm talking about motorcycles
man I love a man there's a fat tire in
the back you know Harley Davidson or an
Indian you know black down and we're
driving probably like 40 minutes 30
minutes in there's Bumper to Bumper uh
what's the matter a motorcycle accident
so it's it's like you're talking about
it there's an accident it doesn't matter
August 31st 1986 Aeromexico and a
private plane over city of Cerritos 84
passengers all dead people on the ground
did yeah
you know you never know what you're
doing yeah a good friend of mine picked
up a coin I mean the sequel said bubbles
and he says oh man it's a lucky coin I
said how in the [ __ ] do you figure
that's a lucky coin look at what
happened yeah and he says what are the
odds of that going down on two planes
I'll never fly without it again oh [ __ ]
is that what you said you were out there
yeah yeah you saw that [ __ ] hit well I
didn't see it in I saw this I was out
there for three days picking up body
parts wow yeah you just never you never
know yeah our friend David Arnold Man
David Arnold just like just went to bed
didn't wake up
but he's on my protection too it's like
around the time of the actually I was
here at uh at uh the ATC Network and I
was driving home right when the lockdown
happened and every gun shop had lines
outside the gun shop and I was like
maybe I should buy a gun and I thought
about it for a little bit and then I was
like you know what let me start with a
bat so now I got this bat in my house so
I was like if somebody shows up with a
baseball I'm ready
yeah yeah uh again thank you man yo
thank you guys great to stay with that
conversation all right